さあ一度プロップスとかを消して一つのコンポーネントをだけにしました
で今までは親コンポーネントからコンポーネントに対して
プロップスでデータを渡す方法について見てきました
今回からは逆にコンポーネントから親コンポーネントに対して
通信する方法について見ていきたいと思います
でまず前提としてコンポーネントから親コンポーネントに対して
プロップスと同じくらい自由にデータを渡す方法はありません
なんでかっていうともしコンポーネントから親コンポーネントに対しても
自由にデータを渡せるようになってしまうと
データの流れが自由すぎてコードの流れが追いにくくなるんですね
だから保守性が悪くなるわけです
なので例えばプロップスもリードオンリーになっていましたよね
だからあくまでもビューズエースにおいては
データの流れは親から子の一方通行で流れるのが基本になっています
まずはその前提を押さえておいてください
ただとはいえ何かしらコンポーネントから親コンポーネントに対して通信できる方法があると
それはそれで便利そうですよね
例えば一つコンポーネントとして
リセットボタン.viewというものを作りますね
でテンプレートを置いてボタンを用意したいと思います
でリセットするボタンとして
もしこのボタンがクリックされたら
このコンポーネントをインポートしている親コンポーネントに対して
ボタンがクリックされましたみたいに伝えられたら便利そうですよね
そしたら親コンポーネント側でカウントをリセットということで0にするみたいな処理をかけばリセットされるわけです
ということでView.jsは子コンポーネントから親コンポーネントに対して
コードの流れが極力分かりにくくならない範囲で通信する方法を用意してくれています
でじゃあそれ何かっていうと
結論から言うとですね
イベントのシステムを使います
どういうことかっていうと
実はView.jsのコンポーネントの中では
$emitという関数を使うことができるんですね
これ引数のところに好きな文字列を取ることができるんですけれども
こんな風に呼び出すことで
リセットという名前のイベントを発生させることができるんですね
だから今クリックイベントのイベントハンドラーに書いているので
ボタンが押されるごとにですね
リセットという名前のイベントが発生するわけです
でこのイベントに対して
親コンポーネント側で
VonRelectiveもしくはアットマークで
こんな風にリセットと
さっきの名前を指定することで
このリセットイベントが発生した時の
イベントハンドラーを付けることができます
なのでもうこの時点で
カウントがリセットボタンを押されたら
カウントイコール0ということで
ちゃんとリセットされるのが分かると思います
Vue.jsはこんな風に
カスタムの独自のイベントを
コンポーネント側で発生させて
で親コンポーネント側で
そのイベントに対するイベントハンドラーを付ける
というシステムにすることでですね
コンポーネントから親コンポーネントに対する
通信を行います
でこれってあくまでも
コンポーネント側では
こういうイベントが発生しましたよということを
親コンポーネントに伝えているだけで
その上で何をするかというのは
常に親コンポーネント側が決めていますよね
なのでプロプスとかと比べると
若干ややこしい方法を取っているんですけれども
こういうシステムになっているので
極力ですね
コードの流れが分かりにくくならないまま
コンポーネントから親コンポーネントに対して
通信することができるわけです
なのでぜひですね
コンポーネントから親コンポーネントに対して
通信をしたい場合は
このイベントを発生させるという方法を
積極的に使ってみてください
でじゃあ子から親に対して
データを渡すことはできないのかと
言うとそれも可能です
それについてですね
次のレクチャーで紹介したいと思います
ご視聴ありがとうございました